welcome back everybody so in the last
few videos we've been talking about
optimal control so if we have some state
space system X dot equals ax plus bu and
y equals CX so X is the state of our
system you are the inputs that we get to
control and Y are some measurements so
if we have our system then we have
essentially shown that if you have
access to the full state measurements if
you have access to X the full state of
the system then you can design an lqr
linear quadratic regulator which is U
equals minus KX and you can stabilize
the system but if you only have access
to limited measurements Y you don't have
access to the full state you have access
to Y then we need to put in this
estimator block and this estimator
something like a common filter so a
common filter is a particular optimal
estimator will estimate the state so X
hat is an estimate of the full state X
and it takes into account measurements Y
and also measurements of what the
control is doing you okay and so what
we've shown in the previous few lectures
this is called optimal control this
essentially lqr is an optimal regulator
the Kalman filter is an optimal
estimator when you put these together
this is called LQG or linear quadratic
Gaussian regulator and regulator just
means that we're trying to drive the
state of the system X to 0 to the origin
I could make this a reference tracking
problem where I try to drive the state
of the system X to some vector Direction
X but if we're if we're stabilizing the
system it's a regulator and what we've
shown is that if the system is
controllable so if a and B are
controllable and if a and C are
observable then it's possible to design
this lqr regulator so
the closed-loop eigenvalues are
arbitrarily stable and it's possible to
design this estimator block so that the
estimate X hat converges to the true
state X as fast as we want and there are
some optimal eigen values based on
trade-offs between accuracy of how fast
you're tracking the state to zero and
how much control you're spending and
also a balance between the types of
noises and disturbances you see in your
system okay and so this broadly speaking
is the field of optimal control but
today we're going to start talking about
a very very important modern perspective
and control theory called robust control
okay
so optimal control has been a mainstay
and is still possibly the most used
state space formulation of control today
so if you have a state space system X
dot equals ax plus bu y equals CX
chances are you're going to start by
developing a lqr regulator and a common
filter but there was a remarkable paper
by John Doyle
so Doyle in 1978 wrote this amazing
paper one of the most important papers
in control theory ever written and one
of my favorite papers called guaranteed
guaranteed margins and this means
stability margins guaranteed stability
margins for LQG regulators ok and I want
to break this down for you ok so
guaranteed margins for LQG regulars this
is the title of John Doyle 1978 paper
and it was well known at the time that
if you actually were measuring the full
state if y equals x and i didn't have to
do a common filter then the lqr
regulator was pretty robust if I had
some uncertainties in my system if my
system was a little bit different or I
had some time delays in my system the
lqr regulator would still be able to
stabilize the system
as long as Y equaled X now what John
Doyle was investigating in this 1978
paper is if I don't have measurements of
X but I have to build up an estimate
using something like a common filter is
this combined LQG regulator still robust
to things like uncertainties in my
system or time delays and so in this
paper one of my favorite things about
this is the abstract abstract there
ain't none well I think the editor
probably made him change it to there are
none one of the simplest and most direct
abstracts there in the literature okay
so what John Doyle showing his 1978
paper is that there are no guaranteed
stability margins for LQG regulators so
depending on my system and the types of
noise and disturbances that I have my
combined lqr and common filter my LQG
regulator might be arbitrarily sensitive
to things like model uncertainty and
time delays it could be arbitrarily non
robust okay this is really a beautiful
paper it's less than one printed page
and it changed the field of control
forever okay so instead so there's this
idea that we could change the
eigenvalues of this lqr regulator and we
can change the eigenvalues of this
estimator to be whatever we want to be
more stable or less stable okay so this
lqr regulator can change the eigenvalues
of the closed-loop system and this
calming filter can change the
eigenvalues of my estimator but what
this paper is showing is that there's
some the stability of this system does
not guarantee that it's robust it
doesn't mean that the system won't blow
up if I have some model uncertainty and
so there's this new concept of
robustness okay and so we're buffness
and performance are now these kind of
dual objects okay so the closed-loop i
ghen values of mice
them and how fast I can estimate our
kind of measures of performance how well
does my persistent perform how fast does
it respond and robustness is more of a
measure of how sensitive is my system to
model uncertainties or time delays or
disturbances things like that and so in
this really fantastic paper this idea
that LQG regulators could have very high
nominal performance but almost zero
robustness really turn the field upside
down and it started this movement
towards robust control okay so
everything I'm going to tell you about
for the next few videos is about robust
control how do we tell if the system is
or is not robust to model uncertainty
how do we even know what that means and
then how do we design a system to have
high performance and high robustness and
what are the trade-offs when can I have
both when can I not have both okay so to
jump into this we're going to need a few
new concepts like the transfer function
and the frequency domain because
oftentimes performance and robustness
are easier to understand in the transfer
function or Laplace transform domain
okay
so that's where things are going we're
going to start figuring out what
robustness means how we can have robust
performance when we can and when we
can't and how to do things like fix our
LQG regulator to make it more robust
okay so that's all coming up and this is
going from optimal control to robust
control thank you